when we wrap this honored one in the DLC
we started thinking about emily kaldwin
as protagonist it became kind of a bit
of an obsession for us
welcome to see Emily and treat her the
right way like think really how would
she grow up what would she look like how
would she carry herself so it's 15 years
after the rat plague after the first
dishonored and Kouros been training her
for 15 years telling her someday our
enemies are gonna come for you with
knives and we have to be ready then
otherworldly usurper takes the throne
for the first time as an adult driven
out of her home she has to flee and so
the contrast for her is huge she was an
empress one day the next day she's on
the run and she's trying to unravel the
Duke of surco nose and his allies in
order to win back her own throne and so
part of it is just like take back what's
yours but at the same time she begins to
see the corrupting influences of bad
leadership our motivation becomes I need
to take back the Empire so that I can do
right by the people when we decided that
Emily got to have her own powers they
needed to be interesting enough to be as
cool as Koval her mobility power is
called far reach where it's it's more
elastic than blink it's not so much a
short-range teleport as it's almost like
a supernatural grapple it allows you to
pull yourself through the world you can
slingshot past things you can grab
people and pull them toward you and
assassinate them in midair
you can pull objects toward yourself far
reach can be upgraded in different ways
domi know it's that power that allows
you to link the fate of characters in
the world and whatever happens to one
happens to the other if you look at her
powers most of them are befitting of an
empress she can link people together so
that they shared the same fate she can
mesmerize a crowd of people
she's also a young woman who lived a
pretty privileged life punctuated by a
brief time of darkness she uses shadow
walking she to come to this inky
monstrosity and then for a brief time
does some terrible things and then goes
back to being the person that she
normally is and then it gets a bit crazy
because he also has the power of
doppelganger what she can create a
reflection of herself
you can be used to distract AI enemies
or it can be upgraded so that it's
actually lethal and it can assassinate
so whether you play Emily or Corvo you
work your way through the same set of
missions but that said Emily's
commentary on the world is sometimes
similar to corvo's but sometimes it's
different based on her perspective I
wish I could just run away from all this
sometimes you do one of the underlying
themes of the game is that Emily as
Empress is used to depending on a lot of
other people to get what she needs and
in this situation she's really only got
herself to depend on and then on top of
that because she is a former Emperor and
Empress on the rung people react very
differently when they see her than they
do to Corvo majesty
you